hold on to your hats everyone um we've
just done part one and part two and you
might think
i'm so exhausted how can we go like all
of that and then again well i promise
this is actually a bit of a downhill
slope which is interesting because um
like i said before only ten percent of
the state um got to the end really of
part four but i actually think um
working wise it's easier but but
thinking wise you you may um you may
start to realize why it was still quite
sophisticated it's part three and part
four
of a question 16 part question for a
reason okay
so let's go have a go at part three and
in fact before i even do that i'm just
going to go all the way back up because
i've forgotten entirely what part three
was even asking so let's go and have a
look there i'm gonna grab this just so
we can have it nearby so there's part
scroll scroll scroll scroll here we go
um and we don't need part one and two
anymore so let's get that out of the
picture
that'll do
all right
what do we do with this piece well let's
just read the question and see what we
can determine um just by just on first
blush right so it says let you know just
sort of interrupts our part one two
three four um working to say let j n
equal there's like a whole new integral
and you're like what how do i deal with
this right but actually even though a
whole new integral sounds like awful
there's so many clues here that actually
help us see the continuity that i think
if we pause and slow down we should be
fine okay so here's the first thing
right
they say let j n equal
this integral and it's defined in the
same space that our in integral was
that's that
part three even like flat out it says
using the result of part two so it's
trying to like slap you in the face and
tell you hey this is it looks weird and
different but it's it's a continuity of
what you've just done in parts one and
part two and then i want you to look
very carefully at what comes up on the
end here this is the result we are
trying to prove here in part 3.
doesn't that look familiar
you've got this n factorial it's squared
you've got a 2n plus 1 on the
denominator factorial that sure looks
like exactly what we got in the previous
question of course they said that
because continue from part two it's just
that there's this bit missing there's a
two to the two n missing on the
numerator so what i'm going to do is
file that away in my brain and recognize
that's kind of my destination i'm
somehow going to have to do that but the
2 to the 2n is somehow going to vanish
right
and then my other thing is when you have
a look at this result which or rather
this integrand which apparently has
something to do with parts one and two
why is it different why does it look so
different the answer is
well this is an algebra this is like a
polynomial of some kind right x to the n
one minus x to the n this is a
polynomial but we started with a
trigonometric integrand right and there
is no trigonometry to be seen in this
question
so we're going to pull the same trick
that we do over and over again when
something isn't there you kind of need
to find a way to put it there in a way
that doesn't violate what the question
is thankfully when you've got an
integral and it doesn't look the way you
want it we have a whole like named
technique for changing the shape and the
the form of the integral to be something
that we can work more easily with and
that is of course integration by
substitution right now remember back in
um
back in extension one you learned
integration by substitution but the
syllabus very clearly stated every time
you have an integration by substitution
will tell you what the substitution is
and part of what lifts you out into
extension two integration by
substitution is um we still make you do
it um sometimes we still give you the
substitution but other times like here
it's like no you're on your own you work
this out extension to your students okay
but i wonder if you can see there's this
inclusion that will help us right
remember
look at what you've got and let's go
back oh how far maybe i shouldn't have
deleted it here we go um
no i need to go a bit further
that'll do there's i am right
look at what you've got here sine the 2n
plus 1 2 theta
what is an appropriate substitution that
will help me get to here or something
like this
from
here here's the jn right
the easy part is there's going to have
to be a sign involved right because
you're like no signs here it's going to
have to be x equals sine of some variety
right
but if you were to just put in say
sine theta okay you're going to get a
sine n theta here
and then a 1 minus sine theta to the
power of n here and as you go through it
doesn't quite pan out you don't get the
results that you need to get to be able
to get to part two and it's result which
we know we need to have some sort of
connection to okay so uh we could go
through that uh in fact i have a earlier
on on this same document i've got my
trial by like i'll just give this a go
and see what happens and i eventually
hit a brick wall just by doing the
substitution you're like oh this is not
going to work right
instead of sine theta what i'm going to
suggest we introduce whoops
is instead x equals sine squared
theta right now i know that is not
immediately obvious why you would do
that
for me it wasn't i just tried sine theta
and i you know tried to see where it led
but i'm going to show you why fairly
quickly you realize sine squared theta
is much more useful okay
to do an integration by substitution we
have to substitute three things do you
remember um you substitute whatever's in
the integrand that needs to be changed
you need to change the variable of
integration so we have a dx at the
moment we're gonna need to change that
into a d theta and thirdly we're also
going to have to
change our boundaries right they're
currently x boundaries when you look
here
that zero and that one implies x equals
zero and x equals one i'm going to
change them into theta boundaries right
so there are the three things
this x equals sine squared theta will
take care of the first thing to do the
second thing we better differentiate so
let's go to dx on d theta okay
it's just sine theta all squared it's a
pretty straightforward use of chain rule
to differentiate so i'm gonna bring that
power down the front i will reduce the
power by one
squared down to one and then i multiply
by the inside derivative which is cos
theta now think think think think is
your brain ticking over yet with
trigonometric identities that will be
useful this is just the double angle
identity for sine and this is the first
sort of like you know like wee green
flag indicator that your hand in the
right direction because you need two
thetas in there right that's why sine
theta um is not going to do it for you
um and in fact even trying to put sine
two theta in there it also doesn't quite
work out in a nice neat way so that's
why sine squared theta is going to do
the job for us
i've got my integrand we'll be ready to
change my i can change my variable
integra of integration i need to change
my boundaries so they used to be x
equals zero and x equals one pretty
standard i hope you can see you're going
to get theta equals zero out of this
because we're in sine and theta equals
pi on 2 for x equals 1. okay
all right so i'm ready to do my
substitution i'm ready to write like
what is jn in terms of all the
trigonometric stuff because it was all
polynomial before so therefore j
and equals integral from
boundaries change they're from naught to
pi on two that's a relief because those
are the same values we had in our part
one and two integral and then um if you
have a look there it's going to be x to
the n which is now sine squared theta
to the n so it's sine
careful with your index laws there
you're going to multiply your indices
theta
and then it's 1 minus x to the n so 1
minus sine squared
to the n
and then oops it does i haven't quite
finished there on the end there i now
have to change that variable of
integration so you can see dx is equal
to sine 2 theta d theta right so
therefore i'm just going to write that
on the m sine 2 theta
d theta
okay so where can i go from here there's
some fairly obvious simplification that
you can do
for starters this term in here this one
minus sine squared you're like hey hold
up um this is the same kind of
pythagorean identity trick that i pulled
before but it's actually going to be
useful to me to reverse it you're going
to see why in a hot minute okay let's
have a go and sort of use this to um
simplify what's going on not to play on
two here
uh sine of two n
theta and then this is going to be
cos squared theta
to the n cos squared theta to the n so
again same deal with your index laws
here cos to n theta because they're
multiplied together
and then you've got this hanging out on
the end there
okay can you see where this is going can
you recognize something a move we just
pulled that's going to be useful to
simplify this integrand even further
see how
both of these terms here raised to the
same power 2m right so i can lump
together that product and raise the
product to the power of 2n so that's
going to be from naught to pi on 2
here comes the product it's just sine
theta cos theta
and that's all raised to the power of 2n
and then here comes that sine 2 theta
hanging out there right
hold up does this not look familiar
right deja vu this sine theta cos theta
when you multiply by 2 that gives you
that double angle right i've got the
same thing here sine theta cos theta i'm
just missing the two
hold up did you hear that missing the
two think about how we're going to need
to adjust this in order to compensate if
i take this same integral
naught to pi on 2 and if i insert the
two that i want to use the double angle
identity so i'm just going to put a 2
there and then everything else is the
same
sine theta cos theta that's raised to
the power of 2n and then everything else
hanging out there
we've pulled this trick a thousand times
right if you change an integrand you
like to introduce some kind of constant
coefficient to make it into a form
that's nice
if you multiply by some constant
coefficient inside you've got to divide
by that same constant coefficient what
is that constant coefficient in this
case just be careful
there's a two there but it's not just
the two is it it's not just one of them
how many twos have we actually
multiplied the integrand by and the
answer is
we've multiplied by two n of them right
so if i've multiplied that many times i
also need to divide
that many times
so now you can see it's all balanced out
oopsie daisy not 2 to the n it's to the
2n right that's bit embarrassing
so i've got
all the twos in here making this the
nice double angle identity and then i've
got the all the twos out here just
keeping my um my whole thing balanced
and i haven't changed it uh and this is
going to make everything work out nice
and neatly for me in the end right
one over 2 to the 2 n what's going to
happen in here not to pi on 2
this
is sine 2 theta right so it's sine 2
theta but it's been raised to the power
of 2n
2 theta
and then all of this here
hold up
hold up
does this look familiar
does it look full circle to you is this
not exactly the trick that i pulled all
the way back in part one can you
remember how long ago that was um all
the way back in part one to break this
thing apart so we could handle it with
integration by parts remember that
but i don't want to do that anymore i
want to go back in the opposite
direction i want to go back to i
n right so therefore i'm going to say
hold up oops it is
i'm going to put this all back together
this is equal to not to pi on 2
and the power the indices rather can be
combined 2n plus 1
2 theta d theta this disastrous thing
here this whole thing here that
is i
and you're like i can't believe i was
watching a movie recently with my kids
called onward and they do this the main
characters go on this big long quest
throughout the whole entire movie and
they arrive at the end of the quest and
they're like wow we made it and
literally the end of their quest is
they've gone back home
and that's exactly what you've done here
you've gone back home and so i can say
well that's 1 on 2 to the 2n
times
i n but all of the work we've done
remember the question part 3 said
here it is using the result of part 2 or
otherwise i haven't used part 2 yet so
let's do that
part two is here
this is part two that i should have said
that that's
i n right so therefore let's just drag
this entire thing into this argument
okay here we go
this is equal to
1 over 2 to the 2n
multiplied by what i already know from
part 2
that's what i n is equal to so i'll even
say from
part 2.
and look at that lo and behold this 2
over 2n that i had to divide by to do
this integration successfully it nicely
cancels with that extra 2 to the 2n up
on the numerator there all along so what
do you end up with
n factorial
squared all over this other factorial to
n plus one factorial
as required
whoa